unidos podemos y podremos superar esta
época de oscuridad en eeuu elegiremos la
esperanza frente al miedo los hechos
frente a la ficción la justicia sobre el
privilegio con estas palabras el
exvicepresidente y ahora candidato
oficial a las presidenciales yo vaivén
aceptó la nominación al finalizar la
convención nacional demócrata
aseguró que eeuu se enfrenta a cuatro
grandes crisis la pandemia de ccoo y 19
la caída de la economía el llamado por
la justicia racial y el cambio climático
eeuu se encuentra en un punto de
inflexión una época de peligro real pero
de posibilidades extraordinarias podemos
elegir el camino de estar más enojados
menos esperanzados más divididos un
camino de sombra y sospecha o podemos
elegir un camino diferente y juntos
aprovechar esta oportunidad para sanar
renacer unirnos sobre la pandemia baile
en cargo contra trump asegurando que le
cayó al país en su deber de proteger al
pueblo y añadió que la nación no
aguantaría cuatro años más con él en el
poder de un presidente que no asume la
responsabilidad que se niega a liderar
que culpa a los otros que acoge a
dictadores y aviva las llamas del odio y
la división él se despertará cada día
creyendo que el trabajo se trata de él
nunca de ustedes esos son los eeuu que
quieren para ustedes su familia y sus
hijos
[Música]
en paralelo al final de la convención el
jefe de estado da una entrevista a un
medio estadounidense en la que resaltó
que las elecciones de noviembre serán
las más fraudulentas de la historia y
agregó que si los demócratas ganan
acabarán con la economía y con el país